the summer heat is faster protein which
makes now the perfect time to get an AC
tune-up power shift by NV Energy the
sponsors of this next segment is
offering low cost and no cost AC
tune-ups for customers take a look
one of the worst things living in Las
Vegas is it's summertime you come home
from work open the front door and the
house is warm your AC is out now instead
of worrying about that day happening you
can prevent it but Jeremy first things
first why is an AC tune-up so important
you know when it's hot in Las Vegas you
want to make sure air conditioner is
working not only that it's working but
it's working efficiently we all know
that on those hot summer days air
conditioner bills can get higher and
when a unit's running as it's supposed
to be as designed by the manufacturer
it'll help keep your bills lower now
when you crew come out and start doing a
service on an AC what are you looking
for when it comes to maintenance what do
you walk me through the process here
sure so what Jeffrey's doing here is
he's actually checking the refrigerant
charge right now he wants to make sure
that one that the refrigerant charge is
right he's also going to be inspecting
the coil to make sure that it's free and
Clean from any debris he's going to be
checking all of the moving Parts your
Motors he's going to be checking your
capacitors to make sure that they are
operating and that the compressors draws
on power are where they're supposed to
be so that it's not only guaranteed to
keep working but it's running as
optimally and efficiently as possible
when you're looking at an AC unit just
for the visual eye can you see anything
wrong with it you have to Deep dive into
this thing to find the issues you know
most of the time we have to Deep dive
that's why Jeffrey's got his iPad here
he's got his gauges here and he's
checking things so that he knows what
it's really doing now
I call it a fear we're just a concern is
that you're going to come out here and
you're going to find something that
needs to be repaired is that what you're
looking for you just want us to have the
best working AC possible you know we
want you to have the best working AC
possible we want to make sure that you
don't have to call us in the summertime
because when it's 110 degrees and it's
Fourth of July you don't want to see us
I'd rather be out at your house when
it's nice outside making sure that it's
continuing to run and that's continuing
to run very efficiently now when it
comes to a tune-up how often should you
should you have it done once a year
every two years or once a year it should
be done once a year absolutely people
watching have never had an ac tune up
raise your hand
I need you to come out to my house done
and you guys also work very closely with
Envy energy within sentence we do
absolutely they're a strategic partner
they have got some amazing incentives
right now to make sure that your system
is operating as a design well this is
Patricia with NV Energy so what are some
of the incentives that you guys offer so
one of the incentives that we do offer
is uh it's a 50 for all customers to get
a tune-up and it's 100 free for income
qualified customers to to get AC
tune-ups it's these are great savings
right there why is it so important for
you to have us the customers get our ACS
tuned up so it's very important during
hot summer months to make sure that you
save energy that you conserve and that
your AC unit is working on Tip-Top
Shades so we want our customers to be
comfortable and to also be able to save
money during the hot summer months and
not it can't be anyone that comes out
here you guys have a list of proved
vendors that can come do the service how
do we get more information yes you go to
our website and there we have the list
of all the qualified vendors that we
worked together with our AC program in
our tune up Pro them
thank you to Envy energy for sponsoring
this segment visit their website
nvenergy.com powershift low-cost
tune-ups 250 income qualified cost
tune-ups that's zero dollars for them
that's I mean great specials they have
going on yeah fifty dollars just to get
a tune-up that's amazing that is the
worst feeling summertime it's 110 you
walk inside your AC is set at 75 and
it's like 82 in your house oh that's the
warmers and looking at the temperatures
behind Ted over there I think we're
gonna need some AC working because it's
heating up Ted this is this is AC
weather for sure yes this is going to
stay on all summer at this point from
here on